hey you dirty Birds think story here
with another season of Castle Rock and
we have a jam-packed breakdown here
combining the first three episodes now
if you're used to my breakdown videos
you know I usually do a detailed
scene-by-scene analysis of every episode
but because of my schedule this week my
hands are tied so I'm focusing this
video on the biggest theories scenes and
events from the first three episodes so
if I missed a detail
my apologies I'll be here next week with
episode fours super in-depth version
let's not waste any time and get right
into it we begin with what appears to be
a young Annie Wilkes the protagonists
from Stephen King's novel misery running
through the force bloodied carrying a
banker's box with the phrase the
ravening angel will see any have several
quick flashbacks of her younger self
throughout the first three episodes
including this wanted poster which says
for unlawful flight to avoid persecution
murder inside the box is a young child
my best guess at this point is that it's
joy
the young girl we see Annie raised while
travelling the country to support her
narcotic addiction what we don't know is
where this child came from and if it's
Annie's at all which my guess will be
one of the bigger mysteries of the
season Annie is on the run from the
police as well as this other character
only known as the tall man the tall man
seems to be the manifestation of this
terrible thing she did in the past that
has come to haunt her only to be quelled
by the use of antipsychotics but it
could also be the manifestation of her
schizophrenia notice how he looks here
and this quick image of Vincent van Gogh
who also suffered from schizophrenia
which is shown when she searches about
her condition and he describes herself
as having two parts saying because I try
so hard to be there for you
to be my best self her use of the phrase
the other one points to this other part
of her that takes control it also means
that Annie is an unreliable narrator
meaning that anything we see from her
perspective we can't take at face value
so keep that in mind as we continue
along any arrives in Castle Rock
crashing your car and is stuck there
until a new windshield can be delivered
and installed she shacks up at the
Stargazer which is run by John Ace
Merrill the main antagonist from Stephen
King's novella the body and portrayed by
Kiefer Sutherland in the film's stand by
me the murals are a prominent family in
Castle Rock with John's uncle pop
Merrill played by Tim Robbins who was
Andy Dufresne and Stephen King's
Shawshank Redemption pop basically runs
the town and has the cops under his
control sending John out to retrieve
money from the Somali refugees who use
his warehouse as a business hub but the
Merrill family is a little more
complicated than that
pop ends up fostering a brother and
sister from Somalia Abdi and Nadia he
even gives Abdi full control over the
warehouse for him to take over when he
dies oh yeah pop has cancer
the main tension between John and Abdi
seemed to stem from John's jealousy
towards Abdi and how pop gives him
everything up until episode 3 we aren't
sure why pop has such a love for the
Somalis who are seen by the other
townspeople as a nuisance taking away
jobs and bringing Islam to their city
all we know is that pop has a secret a
secret both John and Abdi know and is
somehow linked to when he was a soldier
fighting in Somalia my best guess is
that he somehow killed Abdi inaudi 'iz
mother and because he feels responsible
has taken them in but we'll need to keep
watching to find out
Abdi has gone and started his own a new
mall currently under construction in
Salem's Lot allegedly over haunted
burial grounds this new mall pisses John
off leading him to later firebomb his
house a house which Annie is also in at
the time of the bombing because she's
there to steal Nadia's key card which
opens the narcotics room at the local
hospital and he is later caught by Nadia
but instead of calling the police
decides to write her a prescription
like Annie Nadia lost her mother at a
young age and feels
for her she also knows how great a
worker annie has been at the hospital
which has been in dire need of nurses
annie has paid a visit by John who has
found out her real identity and in an
effort to protect herself and her
daughter kills him with an ice cream
scoop
later dumping his body at Abdi's
construction site while burying him she
and the body fall through the cracks
revealing an underground cavern with
several bodies from the year 1619 the
same year Castle Rock was founded over
400 years ago we see two plaques one
which says Damien aucoin oak when I
don't know Damien often a name used to
symbolize the devil along with the
plaque are symbols of beetles beetles
which we see buzzing around castle rock
these first three episodes beetles are
often a symbol of Resurrection and
immortality something that will see
manifest through John's reappearance and
he finds a way through an old sewer
system which feels a lot like it and the
case for John being somehow inhabited by
Pennywise is starting to get more
compelling one he dies near the sewer
two he tells pop that he spent his time
away in Derry the same location where
the events of it take place and three
when he looks at himself in the mirror
his eye does this weird distortion
similar to Pennywise I can't help but
think there's a connection and he falls
the sewers leading her to the Marston
home in Stephen King Salem's Lot this
house was considered to have an evil
presence being the former residence of
Hubie Marston who practiced black magic
and killed his wife and himself it's
implied in the book that Hubie was also
behind the disappearance of four
children in town maybe a bit of a
stretch but here are four children the
house is said to attract other evils and
will later see Hasan uncover these two
burned bodies pop later tells a group at
the bar that the Satanists who once
inhabited this place were burned so
don't count out flashbacks from 1619
happening in future episodes joy starts
to question her mother's past and
tensions between Abdi and pop take a
turn when he's held hostage thinking
he's the one responsible for John's
disappearance after all Abdi has motive
after John fire bombed his house but
here we get a little bit more insight
into the relationship between Abdi and
pop pop
offered to adopt Abdi uh Nadia for
business purposes so it's his business
always which is a total gut punch - Abdi
who like any foster child would want to
be adopted because they have a family
that loves them this resentment no doubt
has caused friction between the two
resulting in Abdi wanting to start his
own mall you hope I killed him because
then would be even fair just business
well we will never be just business we
will never be a family either the end of
episode 2 leaves us with Annie haunted
by the ghost of John Mara who has
seemingly resurrected as we'll see
throughout the episode something has
taken over his body
and has the ability to take over others
as well when we leave him in the sewers
in Episode two he's covered by this
slime slime which will also see covering
the captured police officer in Episode
three it seems like whatever has taken
control of John is starting to infect
more and more townspeople just like in
Salem's Lot vampires began infecting
more and more people Abdi having been
held hostage by pop takes him to the
hospital after pop suffers a mini stroke
meanwhile Andy tells joy to start
packing as she ventures back to the
construction site looking for any signs
of John's return and perhaps for her
necklace which she lost and could link
her to John's murder but when she
arrives she finds the hole has been
covered up it's then she ventures to the
Marston home where she sees her son
eating a raw egg covered in that same
slime and she also tries to open this
locked door
now if season one of Castle Rock is any
indication anytime they show us one of
these locked doors
we're gonna come back to it later so
something in this house is hiding a
terrible secret and it just might be
beyond that door joy goes out with her
friends chants Tim and Veera to Castle
Lake
one of the major settings of season one
for her it's the first time she's
actually had friends and she's longed
for friends for a long time as seen in
the first episode when she stares at a
group of teens enjoying their lives she
opens up yelling the f-word and for the
first time being a kid there's even this
super awkward almost kiss scene between
her and chance interesting to note here
that this sounds heard when joy is
underwater are the same sounds that were
heard in season one
when Henry Deaver and Alan Pangborn were
near the lake joy ventures home to find
the place trashed her mother hasn't been
taking her pills and she tells joy that
she killed John joy then injects Annie
with a sedative that's only supposed to
be used in case of emergencies and if
she has one of her quote unquote spells
she wakes up tied to the bed almost
identical to carla Gugino scare achter
in Gerald's game another film based off
a Stephen King novel
in fact Annie uses shards of glass from
a broken cup to break free just like the
character does in Gerald's game joy gets
a text from chance saying that nurses
saw John at the hospital confirming that
he isn't actually dead this is a relief
to Joy who is almost about to release
Annie until she finds out she hasn't
been taking her pills pills which Annie
believes that doctor is poisoning her
with it's also ironic that Annie ends up
tied to a bed and spitting out her pills
just like Paul Sheldon her captive in
misery does John has enlisted the help
of a real estate agent in purchasing the
Marsden estate and he asks a very odd
question but you're still able to have
children right suggesting that whatever
John has planned involves using her to
have a child it also appears that John
has already started with renovations to
the house which may make it a hub for
evil emanating from the town much like
Shawshank Prison did in season 1 joy
confronts Annie about a lockbox she
keeps hidden in the closet a lock box
which Annie says just holds silly papers
but we know from episode 1 this lock box
contains various license plates and a
gun it may also hold a secret to Joy's
past and he also tells Joy that her
father was a bad man and that he wasn't
actually a war hero but since we know
Annie hasn't been taking her pills and
seems to be a chronic liar combine that
with her bloody flashbacks who knows
what the real mystery behind this past
is Annie also tells Joy that her father
is still alive that he's a very bad man
and he's not gonna stop coming for them
she once again mentions the laughing
place which in the novel misery is where
Annie kept the bodies of her victims
the term laughing place dates back to
19th century african-american folklore
in which the protagonist uses the term
to lure his enemies and escape the
laughing place ends up being a tree full
of angry
and tree symbolism shows up many times
in the first three episodes like here
enjoys sketchbook in Episode one and
also in the background of the Marston
residence Nadia arrives asking if Annie
is doing alright she had previously
called and said she wasn't doing so well
and while joy is busy and he uses the
opportunity to break free from her
confines when joy gets rid of Nadia she
checks on her mother who's in the middle
of escaping and in Annie's fervor cuts
her own daughter a daughter she said a
few minutes ago she'd do anything to
protect once again leading me to believe
Annie is controlled by two different
people joy runs off my guess is two
chances well Annie is visited by the
tall man freaking her out so much she
takes her pills in desperation that's
when the episode ends with the line you
know the story
to kill her but who is the tall man
referring to is it actually joy the
other logical choice this could be
pointing to is Annie's other
schizophrenic half if she's gonna get
better she needs to kill that part of
her castle rock is known for throwing
these curve balls at us and I can't wait
to see what the rest of the series has
in store thanks for watching everyone
make sure to LIKE and subscribe
once again I'll be back next week with
my more detailed episodic breakdowns so
you'll want to stay tuned for that let
me know about what you thought about the
episodes below and catch me on twitter
at big story wotty until next time
remember daddy loves you very much